[Musica]
l'ignoto
ho deciso di parlarvi di lui del futuro
forse perché avendo 24 anni
tanti ragazzi e ragazze della mia età
vivono quel momento di transizione tra
l'adolescenza
e le essere adulti
fatto delle prime responsabilità di un
certo tipo
del primo vero e proprio ingresso in
società potremmo dire con tutti i dubbi
e quesiti le preoccupazioni le domande
ci saremo
cosa faremo e inizia un po costruirsi
quella che è la relazione
complicata
stravagante con il domani
poi però ragionando tra me e me mi sono
detta ferma carolina stoppati un attimo
il futuro non è un argomento
generazionale
non riguarda dei livelli dell'età
specifiche
il futuro è qualcosa che abbiamo in
comune tutti noi
proprio come esseri umani
e quindi ho deciso di rappresentare velo
così
vero
qualcuno di voi magari si stava dicendo
mamma mia che angoscia adesso vi spiego
perché ho scelto il nero anche se in
realtà con i tempi che stiamo vivendo
potrebbe anche starci un pochettino ho
scelto il nero però perché se ci pensate
bene nella scala di colori che noi
abbiamo a disposizione
il nero è l'unico colore che non fa
trapelare nulla
in nero nasconde
il vero non ti fa vedere
avete presente quella sensazione di
estrema attenzione un po sul chi va là
quando camminate in una stanza o in un
corridoio buio
utilizzate al cento per cento delle
vostre possibilità i cinque sensi udito
per sentire se c'è qualcosa o qualcuno
intorno a voi il tatto che stare attenti
a non farvi male in primis magari lì c'è
un tavolino lì c'è un armadio penso la
ma quando eravamo bambini e ci
immergevamo nel buio per le prime volte
noi li avevamo paura
perché non conoscevamo
e allora io vi chiedo ha in piano onestà
se vi va per alzata di mano
quanti di voi hanno paura del futuro
ok qualcuno qualcuno intravedo e se ci
pensate spesso la paura ti colpisce in
maniera diretta da un punto di vista
fisico mi fa venire il mal di pancia mi
irrigidisce non mi fa stare bene da un
punto di vista invece emotivo ansia
preoccupazioni angoscia può colpire la
nostra vita lavorativa
quella privata o addirittura entrambe
pensate ad esempio ai ragazzi che si
laureano all'università e più o meno
tutti vivono un po quella crisi mistica
del troverò un lavoro
troverò un lavoro che era avrà un senso
con la mia laurea
e sono le stesse paure che in un
contesto completamente diverso
vivano le coppie che si separano
genitori o anche senza figli
sicuramente uno dei due spesso di solito
chi viene lasciato in un dialogo molto
intimo con se stesso si sarà chiesto
sarò ancora felice
troverò la mia altra meta
e vi posso dire che io la figlia di
genitori separati
ogni volta che immagino i miei genitori
invecchiare in solitudine
provo sofferenza
e si vede
proprio questa sofferenza quindi voi
immaginatevi il cervello immagina uno
scenario ok che magari non accadrà mai o
magari accadrà e mi genera delle
emozioni e sono le stesse domande che
fanno i bambini quando hanno cinque sei
sette anni genitori gli insegnanti a
scuola e gli chiedono cosa vuoi fare da
grande
e qui abbiamo un gruppo di bambini che
ha già la risposta pronta l'astronauta
il carabiniere la ballerina e poi c'è un
altro gruppo di bambini che dice
ovviamente non lo so perché magari a 5
anni non sa neanche ancora come gira il
mondo giustamente vi ho fatto tutti
questi esempi generazionali per dirvi
cosa che noi siamo sempre stati abituati
inconsciamente
inconsapevolmente a vivere nel futuro in
questa connessione così particolare
anche un po caotica diciamolo quello che
ci tiene in piedi è la speranza
fascio di luce che si apre la speranza
dei genitori in un mondo migliore per i
propri figli la speranza nostra nel
trasformare questo mondo nel quale
mettere al mondo dei figli e della
stessa speranza di mia nonna che ha va
verso i 90 anni e che puntualmente mi
dice nemmeno dc dialetto ma il dialetto
velo risparmio perché non è molto carino
da sentire riguardo mi dice lui abbiamo
già dato
però voi avete un mondo in mano e in
effetti la nonna ragione
la nonna ragione dobbiamo scegliere in
quale battaglia impiegare le nostre
energie
e vi ho fatto tutto questo discorso
straordinario perché noi possiamo dire
tre cose
il futuro non possiamo calcolarlo
il futuro non possiamo prevederlo o
perlomeno non al cento per cento e terza
per l'essere umano
il futuro non possiamo controllarlo
ciò che non puoi gestire
diventa ignoto e l'ignoto fa paura
noi cosa possiamo fare abbiamo una
grande possibilità
che a quella di vivere e presente
e qualcuno di voi magari si starà
chiedendo si arriva questa ragazza di 24
anni che ci dice vivere il presente è
cosa vuol dire vivere il presente
vuol dire esserci ora
guardate l'immagine dietro di me
il nero rappresenta il buio qualcosa che
noi non conosciamo la luce rappresenta
il presente il nostro raggio d'azione
esserci ora vuol dire realmente
ascoltare la persona che ci sta parlando
davanti a noi vuol dire fermarsi
viviamo una vita talmente caotica e
dinamica fermiamoci per capire chi siamo
cosa vogliamo
da noi dagli altri dalla mamma dal papa
dal fratello dal fidanzato dagli amici
vuol dire anche saper cogliere delle
opportunità
buttarsi rischiare sbagliare fare
un'esperienza all'estero perché perché
voglio provare qualcosa di nuovo o
addirittura a cambiare la propria vita
così tablet magari licenziarsi da un
contratto a tempo indeterminato e
mettersi in proprio per qualcuno può
essere follia ma tu credi in quel
progetto
vuol dire anche e spero che
abbiate vissuto almeno una volta nella
vita questa sensazione perché
straordinaria io la vivo ora su questo
palco che energicamente molto attivo e
la vivo ogni volta che guardo la formula
1 dal vivo che vivo con tipo di emozioni
anche con i ragazzi che mi seguono ed è
sentire la vita che scorre nelle nostre
vene
siete vivi
e vuol dire anche avere fiducia nella
vita indipendentemente dalle vostre
credenze ma avere fiducia cosa vuol dire
magari vi arrivano delle proposte di
lavoro che non hanno senso e tutti
chiedi sì certo ma io sarò all'altezza
perché hanno scelto me
non riesce a trovare il quadro della
situazione ma ti butti perché vi dico
questo io lavoro nell'ambito del moto
sport
mai nella vita avrei pensato di fare
questo tipo di lavoro perché ho fatto
tutt'altro sono molto giovane 24 anni ho
studiato ho lavorato in azienda
nell'ambito della moda e ho studiato per
buona parte della mia vita ricettazione
perché quello era il mio sogno più
grande quindi se uno fa la connessione
dei punti dice ma scusa ma tu cosa vuoi
fare alla fine perché niente aveva senso
in realtà poi col senno del poi ho
capito che tutto aveva un collegamento
straordinario perché
è riuscita a lavorare su quelle qualità
che mi sono servite oggi a fare il
lavoro che faccio
avere fede nella vita
là c'è il futuro nel buio qui e lo
vedete bene perché sono illuminata c'è
il presente con la luce
veniamo bersagliati in continuazione da
notizie negative
crisi climatica quella economica la
pandemia la guerra il mio cosa dovremmo
fare
cerchiamo di dare le risposte oggi
costruiamo oggi il nostro domani
agire
scegliere può essere banale ma non lo è
alla mattina mi alzo e dico ok oggi sono
proprio carica voglia andare a lavorare
e sarò molto produttiva un altro giorno
mi alzo dico no oggi proprio non ho poi
magari può essere il lunedì mattina
super presto e non hai voglia di andare
a lavorare e non sarai produttivo sarai
distratto è sempre una questione di
scelte
e purtroppo spesso cosa capita che
l'essere umano nella sua complessità
la vita la dà per scontata vi chiedo a
quanti di voi è capitato
di posticipare qualcosa e domani
per alzata di mano
beccati poi proprio beccato vi ho
sparato in effetti facciamo sempre così
voglio iniziare a mangiare sano
facciamolo domani perché davanti o le
lasagne di mia nonna non posso
ovviamente roma jarle voglio iniziare
andare in palestra perché c'è la prova
costume d'estate no
oggi ho lavorato tanto sono stanco e non
vado
devo dichiararmi alla persona che amo ma
non ho il coraggio e lo faccio domani
devo affrontare un argomento che mi fa
soffrire
non ho voglia di questi bed bugs e non
farò domani è sempre domani ma è un
domani indefinito vi siete mai chiesti
fino a quando ci sarà quel domani
io sì
l'ha vissuto
ed è una cosa che probabilmente mi
segnerà per tutta la vita
avrei sempre voluto dire a una persona
si chiama giuliano
quanto lo
stima si dal punto di vista
si sente questa cosa che è viva dal
punto di vista lavorativo dal punto di
vista umano
con la persona non c'è più
e io quel domani non l'ho mai più avuto
con lui
ma diamo per scontata
e proprio quell immagine che abbiamo
dietro che mi arriva così questo è il
presente e ho scelto il bianco siamo
partiti dal nero e arriviamo al bianco
perché perché se noi oggi spingiamo al
cento per cento in quelle che sono le
nostre possibilità
il futuro che prima era così buio non lo
sarà più sul foglio bianco avete qua
dietro voi potete fare tutto quello che
volete potete scrivere usare i colori
che volete tutte le tonalità della
palette di prima che vi ho raccontato
potete amarlo
potete odiarlo potete lasciarlo scorrere
darlo per scontato o viverlo potete
ritagliarlo buttarlo fate tutto quello
che volete abbiamo parlato del futuro
che non potevamo calcolarlo non potevamo
prevederlo e controllarlo
il presente
posso calcolarlo
ma qualcosina forse sì posso prevederlo
non del tutto certo ma se faccio delle
azioni so che forse ci saranno anche
delle conseguenze ma il terzo punto che
quello più importante per l'essere umano
come siamo noi io il presente posso
gestirlo e controllarlo
ciò che posso gestire
non fa paura e non è ignoto
siamo in un teatro e ne approfitto di
questo straordinario scenario che mi fa
venire la pelle d'oca per dirvi cosa un
esempio molto semplice a teatro guardate
questa luce ok se mi tiro indietro ora
qui siamo molto illuminati ma se ci
fosse buio
quando magari davanti a un monologo
qualcosa del genere io mi giro indietro
quello è il buio e del mio passato io mi
giro in avanti non vi vedo vedo alcuni
di voi futuro buio
mi guardo i piedi li guarda un po che di
una destra un pochettino a sinistra
questo è il mio campo d'azione mio
raggio di luce che vi ho detto prima
occhio di bue questo il presente
il futuro non inizia domani
il futuro inizia oggi
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]